immagino pensiate che sia fin troppo
evidente quanto la mia immagine così
come si presenta ai vostri occhi possa
legittimare la mia presenza qui oggi a
parole di cyborg essere metà uomo e metà
macchina che sembra arrivato dalla più
algida figurazione della tecnologia
sofisticata o dalla più bizzarra
immaginazione fantascientifica
in realtà l'invito che bilancio è
provare ad immaginare quanto questa
metafora questa immagine possa
suggerirci delle suggestioni per
ripensare il nostro modo comune di
costruire conoscenza e di rintracciare
nell'esperienza quello che conta il
cyborg indica appunto questa condizione
di innesti tecnologici in un organismo
umano e appartiene al mondo della
finzione dell'immaginazione quanto della
realtà più vicina alla nostra esperienza
la mia situazione è una situazione da
faible come lo è banalmente l'innesto di
un pacemaker o come lo è la condizione
di tutti nel momento in cui utilizziamo
in maniera sempre più pervasiva no le
tecnologie
odierne come non più come l'utilizzo
dello strumento ma con una protesi della
nostra estensione la portata concettuale
del cyborg però anche rintraccio nella
mia esperienza e che trovo interessante
come ispirazione per ripensare ad un
nuovo modello di costruzione di una
soggettività rivoluzionaria non si
limita al dualismo alla all'ibridazione
che questa figurazione rappresenta
oltretutto l'ibrido non è una figura
moderna basti pensare senza sforzare
troppo alla mitologia greca alla
tragedia greca alle figure alle figure
mitologiche metà uomo e metà animale la
radice della parola ibrido significa
proprio opposizione insolenza la
tracotanza quella di chi chi si macchia
di brees quella di chi si oppone ad un
ordine precostituito che vede la specie
umana di pisa da dalla dimensione divina
e da quella degli altri degli altri
caduti viventi la dimensione del libro
quindi è quella dell'opposizione ad un
ordine precostituito della trasgressione
che è quella che ha comunemente ispirato
semmai tutto un un humus di una
rivoluzione culturale che si è basata su
un pensiero dualista che vedeva tutta
una serie una costruzione della
dell'alterità in opposizione
l'opposizione ad una ad una figura di
riferimento quindi un'identità che
veniva un'alterità che veniva ripensata
come valorizzante rispetto alla norma
la poetica che immagino invece per il
cyborg come figura ispiratrice è una
potenza che si nutre delle suggestioni
del possibile e e che vive un'esperienza
che è di estasi
ma non era maniera trascendentale come
ce le immaginiamo ma letterale cioè di
un vivere fuori se stessi in maniera del
tutto connesso con quello che è la
configurazione dell'ambiente in cui
viviamo per poi come esperienza del
possibile gli è stata la ispirazione una
citazione che vorrei leggesse se il
senso della realtà esiste e nessuno può
mettere in dubbio che la sua esistenza
sia giustificata allora ci deve essere
anche qualcosa che chiameremo senso
della possibilità un'esperienza
possibile o una possibile verità non
equivalgono ad un esperienza reale ea
una verità reale meno la loro in realtà
ma hanno almeno secondo i loro devoti
qualcosa in sé un fuoco uno slancio una
volontà di costruire non consapevole
utopismo che non si sgomenta della
realtà bensì data adatta come un compito
è un'invenzione
ecco mutuando il linguaggio cibernetico
che studia come ambito scientifico in
maniera trasversale organismi umani come
sistemi sociali e sistemi naturali
esiste mette piccioli in chiave di
comunicazione e di controllo come
elementi interconnessi
la realtà è
no il nostro compito è a nostro piacere
di confondere e ridefinire i confini di
quello che è l'esperienza che valga come
tale quindi vorrei lasciarvi come come
l'ha chiamata una sorta di chiamata alle
armi e questa è la nella conclusione noi
chiamiamo la libertà riusciremo
certamente a descrivere la cultura in
modo che rifletta le nostre esperienze
il nostro vissuto e faremo il mondo che
il complesso il molteplice si
trasformino in una rete di legami
potenzianti che servono da punto
d'accesso verso infinite possibilità di
esistenza di invenzione e di piacere di
vivere
taibo ii del mondo unitevi